overcome with emotion these families are
being reunited
after hurricane iota ripped through
their homes in colombia
the desperation of seeing their
neighborhoods destroyed
the fear of losing their loved ones and
the relief of survival
are too much for some no
expectation i can't explain it it's the
worst thing a human can experience
now there are people on the streets
sleeping on the streets
they've been airlifted from the island
of providencia
and this is what they've left behind the
military's been called in to help with
the cleanup
and what will be a long road to recovery
we know that the reconstruction
challenge is going to be enormous due to
the total destruction of a lot of the
infrastructure
the important thing is that in the first
100 days of intervention
we will have humanitarian assistance and
will be able to help the most affected
families
the storm unleashed winds of around 250
kilometers an hour
and record rainfall swelling rivers and
triggering mudslides across central and
south america
rooftops dot the sea of muddy water in
honduras
where tens of thousands were forced to
flee to shelters
we're thankful to god thankful to those
who arrived and helped the children
above all else
the atlantic has seen a record storm
season this year
scientists say warmer seas caused by
climate change
are making hurricanes stronger for
longer after landfall
many of these areas were battered by
another major hurricane
ita just two weeks ago authorities in
billwe in nicaragua
say anything left standing after that
storm was destroyed
this time round shelters already packed
after eta
are now overwhelmed with new arrivals
i'm homeless right now i'm in a shelter
but at any moment they could kick me out
and i don't know where to go and it's
not over yet
there are more warnings of
life-threatening flash flooding
from the heavy rain in iota's tale
alexia o'brien al jazeera